قد يصل 250 شخصا جديدا الى هذا العالم لكن
التساؤل الرئيسي هل تستطيع الارض استيعاب
كلها هؤلاء البشر وماذا عن الموارد
المتاحه ثمانيه مليارات نسمه هو رقم
المتوقع للبشريه بعد اسبوع وذلك ربما يعني
ان القضاء على الفقر مكافحه الجوع سيصبح
اكثر صعوبه واننا بحاجه الى نحو كوكبين
الا ربع من الكوكب من الارض لتلبيه
احتياجات البشر بطريقه مستدامه هذه هي
الروايه الاكثر شيوعا لكن هناك وجهه نظر
اخرى النمو السكاني يستدعي احتفالا ايضا
بانجازاتنا في مجالات الصحه التي ادت الى
اطاله العمر خفت معدلات وفيات الامهات
والاطفال خبراء اخرون يرون ان الغذاء
الموجود يسد حاجات جميع البشر من الناحيه
الحسابيه لكن السلوك الانسان وخياراته
اخطر من الزياده السكانيه في حديداتها
الدول الكبرى تتكاسل عن ايجاد حلل حقيقي
وبدل من تعديل سلوكها المرتبط باستنزاف في
موارد الكوكب ووقفه وتقليل انبعث الكربون
تستمر في القاء اللوم على الدول الناميه
لدفعها النمو السكاني
[موسيقى]
اذا ثمانيه مليارات نسمه هو عدد السكان
الذي سيصل اليه العالم في منتصف نوفمبر
الجاري وفقا للامم المتحده ما يعني ان
الارض رحبت بمليار انسان اضافي في نحو احد
عشر عمل واليكم مزيدا من الارقام واحد 81
مليون انسان هو متوسط معدل الزياده في عدد
سكان الارض كل عام وثلاثه بالمئه هي نسبه
الزياده السنويه لسكان العالم الذين
يبلغون اعمارهم 60 عاما في اكثر 8 بلدان
ستكون مسؤوله عن اكثر من نصف الزياده
المتوقعه في عدد سكان العالم حتى عام 2050
مصر والكونغو اثيوبيا ونيجيريا وتنزانيا
في افريقيا ومن اسيا الهند وباكستان
الفلبين
77.2 عاما هو متوسط العمر المتوقع للانسان
في عام 2050 9 مليارات شخص فاصل سبعه هو
والسكان المتوقع عام 2050 رغم ذلك ستشهد
واحد وستون دوله بل احدى وستون دوله
تراجعا في عدد سكانها في نفس العام واخيرا
ملايين شخص هو العدد المتوقع لسكان العالم
الذين يبلغ اعمارهم 80 عاما واكثر عام
2100 على كل حال سالنا الناس عدد سكان
العالم سيبلغ 8 مليارات نسمه هل انت
متفائل بمستقبل البشريه او متشائم ولماذا
دعونا نستمع لاجابات الناس من الاردن
[موسيقى]
طبعا المتفاعل مستقبل بشريه البشر على مر
العصور في عندهم ابداعات وعندهم اختراعات
في حضارات سابقه وراح يكون اكيد في
انجازات القادمه فان شاء الله القادم افضل
يكون للبشريه كلها ان شاء الله كله خير
8 مليون 18
تفائل انه
يزيدوا البشريه ولو زادوا البشريه يعني مش
هياثر على الكره الارضيه يعني اللي بنسمع
وانا بنشوفه غلط لان الكوره فاضيه اصلا
يعني طلعنا على مستوى الاردن يعني بس في
عمان اطلع عن طريق المطار بتلاقيها فاضيه
لا هذا الشيء يدعو الى التشاؤم
صعب اني اقول لك ليش لانه الموضوع يعني
تروح سنه بتكلموا فيها موضوع
السكاني والتضاعف الديموغرافيا هذا كبير
متشائم يعني بالنسبه نحنا هسه احنا تمانيه
مليار وصلناهم اول شيء اقتصاد الدوله يلا
نكفي الموجودين
نعمل ولا موفرين شغل ولا شيء يلا الواحد
قادر يسكر يسلك حاله بالاكل الوضع الماديه
بالنسبه للغلاء البنزين غلاء المعيشه غلاء
كل شيء هو بصراحه شايف الامور زايد عن
حدها كل الناس صار تضخم بالسكان كل ما زاد
عندك المصاريف فهذه بتاثر سلبيا كبير
بالنسبه الاقتصاد العالمي والمحلي
[موسيقى]
من القاهره
مشاهد سمر يسعد صباحك اهلا بك اليوم يبلغ
عدد سكان مصر نحو مئه واربع مئه مليون
في مستشفى يا سمر في بيت اتفضلي
صباح الخير عليكم
مليون في سبع شهور تقريبا
رغم مجهودات الدوله اللي بتعملها لتنظيم
الاسره والحملات اللي بتروح الكره والنجوع
ولكن عندنا مشكله في مصر العادات
والتقاليد المترسخه عند الاسره المصريه
صعب شويه تغييرها او جهاز الاجيال الجديده
انا شايفه دلوقتي هتبتدي تغيرها
انا بحب العيله الكبيره بحبك
[ضحك]
هم اثنين زي ما يجوا ولا دين ماشي بنتين
ماشي ولد وبنت ماشي انا عن نفسي كان نفسي
في توام مره واحده يعني
الحمد لله يعني احنا اكتفينا بهم وغيرنا
فكره بقى ايه لا لازم تخاوي البنت لازم
تجيبي لها اخ يبقى سنه اديكي اااه
وغير الزن بقى
من اخواتي من صحابي من حماتي عايزين ايه
بقى بيقولوا لك ايه لا لا خوي العيال لا
اثنين مش كفايه مش ناويه تجيبي بيبي ثاني
على طول على طول كده اسمها ولا اي حاجه
ههه
لا هم اثنين يعني الحمد لله ربنا يبارك لي
فيهم واعرف ايه اربيهم كويس كويس
الاولاد في الصعيد
لا انا كسرت القاعده بتاعتهم ههه غيرت
المفتاح
الوضع ايه انت عندك ثلاث اولاد
ايه بقى انت كنت عايزين ثلاثه ولا انت
مخططتيش ولا
كنا اثنين بس
ما كناش مرتبين للصراحه بس هو عاوز بنت بس
انا عملت له لا هو كده حلو قوي بنات ثانيه
وعيال ثاني لا عشان بصراحه
تعرضت برده الضغوط من اهل انك تخلفي اكثر
لا لا مش حبنا اجيب عيال كثير
هي جايبه جايبه كثير بس هي قالت لي لا
كفايه كده انا تعبانه كثير
يخشو سباق مين هيبقى
بنات اكثر لغايه لما
طيب انا سؤال اخير هل قصه وصلنا ل 8 مليار
نسمه في العالم هل انتم قلقانين على
مستقبل الاولاد هل انتم بتفكروا كده اه
طبعا
قلقانين عليهم
تمام شكرا جزيلا يبدو ان احنا على مشارف
تغيير كبير في المجتمع المصري الشباب
الجديد يعني مش عايز عيله كبيره الان من
مستقبل جايز وشكرا يا سهام شكرا نادين رغم
كل الازمات ما زالت البشريه تتكاثر حياه
تنجب حياه الله